but i want to pick up
where we left off on monday and we were
talking about the three
brave lattices there are a couple more
things that i want to say about them
what we what we captured the key essence
apart from there being these cubic
crystals and and the different elements
that
that form them is this idea that you can
go
from the unit cell right
you once you know the unit cell you
could get the atom
the atomic radius atomic radius right so
that's kind of cool
because you know information about
things like for example
uh packing right so then we had the
packing fraction the atomic packing
fraction
calculated that right the maximum
the max packing fraction right
packing fraction
uh we calculated things like the close
pack direction
okay but you can also go to things like
the density once you know how to go back
and forth
right and and so for example if i had
if i want the density of a material
that's grams
per centimeter cubed right that's the
density
right but you you could write the
density in terms of the things we talked
about on monday so again
you know i want you to be able to go
back and forth once you know that
the unit cell and and you you know
you can know something about the the
radius of the atom maybe then you can
get the density for example here
um the density could be defined as
the number of atoms
in the cell right times
the grams per mole of that element
divided by the volume
of the cell of the unit cell right
times avogadro avogadro
avogadro now you can go through the
units and you can work out that this is
grams per centimeter cubed
right but and so so just as an example
right if i had uh let's see the example
i have is copper
so example copper right
so you know everything comes from the
periodic table
everything life class everything comes
from the periodic table
so i go to the i say i want to know
stuff i go to the periodic table
and instead of looking up the density i
look up other things
so i look up for example that it's fcc
right and then i look up that it's
63.55 grams per mole
okay and i also look up the atomic
radius so i look up these
things right the atomic radius
and that's equal to 1.3 angstroms
so i look all this stuff up and the
point is i can now
go back and forth i can use the
information because i know if it's a
crystal
and i know the crystal type fcc
then i can use this information to get
other other aspects right so other
properties so for example
i know that the radius of the atom
for an fcc if it's close packed is for
if it's
if it's you know fcc one element
remember it grows out until they touch
right and and that got us how we get the
radius of the atom
and it's a root two over four
well i also know that there's four atoms
per unit cell
because it's fcc i also know that the
volume
of the cell is simply the lattice
constant cube because it's a cubic cell
all the ones
here are cubic so the volume of these
cells are given from this information
i can compute the density right so again
it's it's it's going back and forth
right the radius
of the atoms packed in the lattice
constants the number of atoms in the
cell these are the things we talked
about on monday
and you can as you go back and forth you
can do things like this
okay all right good okay
now we talked about the
we talked about the uh the brave lattice
there
right and those are three bravais
lattices that i want you to know
brave
lattice but the thing is that
there's one there's something else you
need to know
in order to know what crystal you have
right
and so this is the fcc bravais lattice
and there it is it's over there on the
right it's the face centered cubic
okay because then tight um and i'm gonna
i'm gonna pass this around
all right oh yeah i'm starting over here
because i keep on starting over there
and it's not fair it's not right yeah
all right cut a couple of okay
now um okay so that's fcc right so we're
going to write down fcc but the thing is
that see
this is a stamp remember we emphasize so
many
it's a stamp of points
that are equivalent that's what the
lattice
vectors are they are not the things that
you put at that point
that is something else now on monday we
put the things there
were atoms spherical particles and
they're all the same
that was our introduction to
crystallography but
the basis
the basis can be more than just a single
atom
it can be more so how do we think about
the basis
right so here's a lattice this is a
lattice of points i haven't
the way you want to think about a
lattice is a stamp without putting
things there yet
the basis is what you put there let's
write that down because it's so
important okay so the the lattice
the lattice is oh we're going
oh i'm going all caps how
to repeat okay and
the basis is
what
to repeat okay
so if this is my lattice and i decide
that i want to get a million downloads
on youtube i'm going to put a cat there
and this is my crystal it's a crystal of
cats
that's okay i have done nothing wrong
because i have simply you know according
to the rules of crystallography i've had
a lattice and a basis and i've just
defined my basis as a cat
and that's that's the crystal you get
but see the bases could also have been
for example
two atoms colored you know differently
to show that they're different atoms
and then this would be my crystal so the
actual crystal
that you get may be different
than the lattice structure right so
let's take a look so for example
over here you know if my basis
is a single atom nickel
copper gold platinum
well i showed you these from the
periodic table on monday right we
highlighted them when we talked about
fcc
then the crystal the crystal that you
get
is fcc these are the ones we did on
monday
right those are fcc crystals but but at
the same time if my base is
check this out oh
the this is salt
when you guys pour salt on your food do
not see it
anymore except as this this is salt
this is salt it is uh
let's see simple cubic
is it though because a lattice
a simple cubic remember the definition a
simple cubic lattice would mean a stamp
right of a simple cube where every
corner is exactly
the same exactly the same that's what a
lattice is so this cannot be a simple
cube
this is not simple cubic because they're
different
they're different right at the corners
i've got two blues and then two reds and
then two other blues
so they're not the same it cannot be a
simple cubic structure
this is an fcc lattice this is an fcc
yeah i'm starting over here again i'm
trying to even it out
that's an fcc lattice but with a basis
with the basis of sodium and chlorine
so it's an fcc you can call it an fcc
lattice
but the basis is a sodium chloride pear
and this has a name it's called the rock
salt structure
it's called the rock salt structure it's
an fcc lattice with this two atom basis
where
look you can see the fcc lattice here
look at those blue
points right blue outlines in fcc
lattice but now the basis
is one atom here and one there so now i
take that
this pair and i put that at all the
lattice points
you see that you put that at all the
lattice points of fcc
and you've got salt and that is how you
must see table salt from now on
well we talked about diamond
this is diamond what diamond is the same
bravais lattice it doesn't look like it
at first
it doesn't look like it at first but see
here
here i have a different pair
here i have a carbon-carbon pair or it
could be
or silicon silicon there are actually
a number of pairs of atoms
that would form this diamond
in fact we specify because there are
different types this is called cubic
diamond
crystal
this is the cubic diamond crystal what
is the lattice
it's fcc it's fcc now let's take a look
at that
look there's my fcc here
here here here right but inside of the
scc i've got this pair of carbon atoms
so
now they're the same type of atom and
instead of one being kind of in the
middle of this edge
as it was with sodium and chlorine now
the other atom is kind of
often a diagonal but it's still just a
pair
of atoms it's a pair of carbon atoms but
if you look carefully at diamond and
this
doesn't go on in this picture but it
does in in real life
this is an fcc lattice of these pairs
repeating everywhere that's what diamond
is
it's an fcc lattice so the symmetry
is fcc but the basis
is a carbon-carbon dimer right
and that gives you cubic diamond
okay so there's there's the brave
lattice
and there's the resulting crystal
structure now
speaking of diamond and this is a graph
that i showed you
a while ago when we were talking about
the differences between
diamond and graphite one of the things
that you can see that's so important
this is the same element two different
crystal structures one of the things
that you can see that's so important is
how direction is going to be
an important property you need to know
how to identify
direction because in you know in this
case it looks like maybe if i point in
different directions
the thing would look kind of the same
right and maybe have
similar properties along but look at
this this looks seriously directionally
dependent
it looks like if i if i did something
like tried to carry charge or
or thermal energy this way then it would
be very very different than if i carry
it this way
well we have a word for that right
that's called anisotropy
and so this is
another important word anisotropy
the property if it's anisotropic then
the property
well it could be like electrical
or thermal conductivity for example
thermal conductivity could be like where
it how it breaks
the fracture right and so on
but whatever the but that the property
is uh
um depends it's i'll just say it's
directionally dependent
directionally
dependent so the reason i'm telling you
this is that
i now need a way i've we've come up with
sort of ways to talk about
crystals right but i i now need a way to
specify
where i am in a crystal and and maybe
how the crystal cuts
right i need a way to talk about
directionality
in these crystals and that's what i want
you to
that's that's the topic for today all
right so the first question
so so well so to jump to the the the
punch line is there's these things
called miller indices that's what we're
going to learn today
miller indices and they describe
direction and cuts
planes okay and the first question you
can ask is where are you
now where are you now it turns out that
there
are um there are these people called
crystallographers
and they came up with crystallography
over the years
and they have very strong ideas
about notation so we'll be talking about
crystallographer notation
and we'll be very careful not to do
anything that would upset
a crystallographer because that is not
something you want to see
but but the the first question that you
could ask
is where are you so i'm going to draw
the planes and we're going to the
the axes we're always going to use the
same notate
the same axis directions just for
simplicity in this class we're going to
say that
you know as we're talking about crystal
structures that's y that's z
and that's x x is coming out of the
board y is going that way and z is going
that way
okay now if i if i want to know where i
am then what i can do is draw the cube
oh boy here we go okay there it is
all right and i can just start looking
at points but instead of having
all sorts of different numbers
crystallographers like to work
with simple numbers so what we do is we
define the position
as the fraction
of the cell edge
okay so what that means is if i you know
so okay first of all the origin is 0
0 0 right so that's 0 0
0 but it also means that you know if i
had this point here
that's going to be 1 0 0.
it doesn't matter what a is remember a
is the lattice constant it's the it's
the size the edge of the cube
which has a real value in different
crystals right there's copper
there's a and copper which we could
compute
but no when we specify positions in
crystal we
we do it as a fraction of that of that
length okay so that
that's for so this point for example
would be one
one one out there all right
and and let's do one more at this point
here right well that's going gonna be
good and tight that's gonna be
you know okay over a half now
so it's a half and then
one zero it went over a half
over one up zero so it's a half okay
good
this is just where we are we're just
getting warmed up but really what we
need to know
is where we're going and that goes from
a point to a vector
okay now again there are some fairly
straightforward
rules that we follow not that we don't
know what vectors are
we know what vectors are the point is do
we know how to specify a vector
in a way that a crystallographer would
be happy with
that's what we have to learn because
again we don't want to make them
upset so there's a set of very simple
rules
that you can follow and i've got this
for the direction and i've got this for
the planes
so here are the rules for the direction
here's a vector in a crystal
origin o and here are different vectors
and what we do
is we okay we position it to start at
the origin and then we read off
the projections in terms of the unit
cell dimensions
a a is x right
b is y and c is z now we know that those
have the same length in a cubic crystal
okay adjust to the smallest integer
values that's really important
and in close and square brackets no
commas
so let's do a few right so o
a uh
here are the x y z
the x y z readout well you know this is
one this is zero
this is zero so this would give us this
as the notation for the oa vector you
see that there right
notice i've already done step two so the
second bullet there read off projections
in terms of unit cell dimensions a b and
c
because it went all the way to the edge
so it's a one
it didn't go halfway it's not a half
right okay good
so ob okay well that's going to be
1 along x 1 along y and 0.
so that direction would be written as
the 1 1 0
and oc would be one
one one this is feeling kind of
boring oh gesundheit but it gets
exciting
in just a sec because all we're doing
here is we're going okay one
zero zero right one one
zero one one one okay
good oh but now we go to od
now od is one of these cases where we
have to be careful
right so od you see that it's going from
here
to there so along the x direction
it's still going a full one of the edge
along the y direction it's zero
oh but along the z direction it's a half
and so because crystallographers don't
like fractions
when they talk about directions we have
to scale that up
and so we just get rid of it we multiply
everything by two
we put it in brackets and everyone is
happy
two zero one that is the two zero one
direction
in this crystal that is the two zero one
direction
they don't like fractions no they don't
like negative signs either
they don't like negative signs but so so
if i were doing oh
d if i were doing o e okay that's just
going in the other direction
but so o e you know o e
would be uh let's see minus
okay well if i just jump to the to what
we think it might be
given what we just saw it would look
like that but crystallographers don't
like having negative
you know these minuses inside of their
brackets so we we write a bar
so we write it like this 0 1 bar
0. and that is the notation for going in
the negative direction
okay 0 1 bar 0.
that would be o e did i get that right o
e yeah
and you can see that o f if you if you
have the same kind of fund
you would see that o f is
the 1 1 2 direction that that's how you
would write the o
f vector right because you go a half a
half
a half a half and then and and one but
they don't like the half so you multiply
through by two you get the one one two
right these are vectors and crystals now
there are uh equivalences here because
this is a cubic lattice
right so you know if i look at this and
say well
okay if i went this way and i went that
way where i wind up are equivalent
points
right where i wind up is is is
you know you're winding up at the same
place in a way in the crystal because
the definition of that stamp in a cubic
lattice is that those are all equivalent
it doesn't matter what's on your basis
right
because it's defined by the bravais
lattice
that's the stamp okay so so we have a
way of writing that too right so if i
were to take so so the 101 that's the
101 direction in the 110 direction
cool um if i make it a little simpler
you know i can say that the 100
and the 0.10
and the 001 oh let's do them all
and the one bar ooh
and the o1 bar o
and the 001 bar all get me to equivalent
places
and we can call this a family just
because we don't want to keep
writing them if they're all equivalent
we can we can say this is a family
of directions and you got to be careful
here
because you can't use a bracket anymore
because it would just be one of the
directions instead
we use uh sorry you can't yeah you can't
use a square bracket instead we use this
kind of bracket
and we say it's the 100 family
so if you see a direction written with
brackets like that
but then it means all of these
directions
this family of directions right but if
you see it written with a bracket like
this
it means that one vector okay
crystallographers you got to keep them
happy you got to keep them happy
all right now that is
directions that is direction
but what about cuts what about planes
so we've got our vectors now we need our
cuts we got to be able to specify these
things
and you know as we'll see
as we'll see the the properties
of of of materials of crystals
especially the more anisotropic they are
depend very heavily
on what's in what direction right
so for example if i have a plane in a
crystal
that doesn't have a high density of
atoms and then i got another plane
that's got a lot of density of atoms in
that plane
well you might expect those to have
different responses
to for example mechanical stress strain
right let's say you push it you pull it
you break it you hammer it
maybe one of those planes if it doesn't
have as many bonds in it
right mike might break first this is one
example so
we got to know how to talk about these
things we got to know how to talk about
these things
okay so now with planes i have another
recipe
to make crystallographers happy
okay now first read off intersect oh
well let's put an example up
so i've got an example i'll do a few and
then as always
you guys need to do more to practice
right so i'll do a few
so i'm going to draw a plane and i'm
going to make it a nice
simple one here's my these are my axes x
y z and i'm going to draw my
cubic crystal my cubic unit cell sorry
okay here we go and almost
a cube okay now
i want to take a plane here i'm going to
take this top one so i'm going to take
this
and i'm going to go through those i want
to know how do i describe that plane
that cuts that way
okay so
one these correspond to those crystal
plane algorithm
algorithm i hear a few of you
like algorithms and computing of course
six
and so we got one whistle
so here's the thing if i have a plane
like this
and i ask you where does it intercept
where does it intercept the axis right
well it's never going to intercept the x
and y
axes never
it's never going to intercept them no
matter what i do
you say but what if i put it in the x y
plane then it's it's always intercept no
that's not what we mean by
intercept right what i mean by intercept
is
it has to reach them eventually no
matter where it is
no matter where i position it it's got
it but this never does
this never does right and so the the
intercepts
you know for for the the the abc
intercepts so we can write those here a
okay i'll write the same way x y z
intercepts
it's infinite and it's infinite
all right and then for the for the z
okay here
i'm intercepting at this at this part of
z
so i'm intercepting at one but the thing
is oh
man crystallographers don't like
infinity either
they don't and so what they do is they
just take one over
that's a nice way to fix infinity and so
step two this would become zero zero
and one over one is one right
one over infinity is zero
now we reduce to integer values and that
there's no work to do there and then
we are very careful about this
we use parentheses no more brackets
parentheses do not get this
wrong because you you might be talking
about a vector
by accident you don't want to talk about
a vector by accident so this is the zero
zero one plane no commas
remember the dislike of commas
it's the zero zero one plane in this
crystal
that is a cut okay good and that's
called a miller plane
well if i if i do another example do one
more
and so that is
that is this one i have it i've got a
bunch of examples here
and they can draw it you know better
with the shading and stuff there but you
see that's what we just did we did the
001 plane that one there right
there it is nice and big the 001 plane
uh what what about that one that's the
1-1-0
the 1-1-0 if you if you do the 1-1-0
1-1-0 i'm not going to try to draw it
again what you get is
step one you get one
one infinity step two you get one
one zero step three you get one one
zero and step four you get one one zero
those are the steps to identifying and
labeling a crystal plane
let's make it a little more complicated
see you know we still haven't really
done
something where we take advantage of the
rule
of step three so let's make it harder
let's bump it up
so there's a slice remember i can slice
the crystal
in any way i want and i got to be able
to write it down i got to be able to
represent it
on paper that's what this is about
that's what the miller indices and the
miller planes
let us do okay well so this one i'm
going to try to draw so
so here i've got my axes and that's y
and that's x and that's z here we go
okay
oh it's almost a cube now i've gone up
here to three quarters high so i've gone
up about three quarters there
i've gone here to a half that's a half
right of of the cell length this is
three quarters
of the cell length and then over i've
gone all the way to one
so now if i go through my steps on this
one i've got
a half and i've got one
and i've got three quarters okay i'm
gonna take the reciprocals
okay that becomes two one four-thirds
oh not happy yet
not happy yet we don't like fractions we
got to get rid of fractions so in step
three
we simply multiply through by three and
we get
six three uh four
and then we can write down that plane
that is this six
three four plane okay
and so on and so on now
let's go back to let me erase this
there's a couple things about
the planes that once we know what the
plane is
we know some other things about it okay
so let's talk about that now
all right if i
first of all
a miller plane is not just one plane a
miller plane is not just one plane
a miller plane is an infinite set of
planes
okay so when i say a miller plane
well very often
what you do is what we've been doing
right you know
which is you define the plane that's
kind of closest somehow to the origin
right in the unit cell the one that cuts
it you define it that way
but actually what miller planes are
infinite sets of planes
and so i'm gonna put now i'm not a
crystallographer
so i can write infinity i'm okay with
that
it's an infinite set of planes
okay they are equally spaced
equally spaced
and here's the key one should always be
going through the origin if you want to
look at it as a set of planes
you got to put one at the origin that
will help you think through
what i mean okay so
so if if one
goes through the origin
then what you see right away
is how they repeat and because you know
it's not just that i go in in that case
you know let's take that one okay the
001.
now you say where's the next one in this
infinite set of planes
okay we'll put that one at the origin
and make another one
then put that one at the origin again
and make another one that's how to think
about this infinite set
of planes okay but so if i if i had one
that went halfway
a 200 plane or an 02 plane
as it would be if it's properly noted
with miller indices
well then you say well okay i've got one
halfway
you know isn't that it no the set of
infinite planes
also would have one at the origin one
halfway one at the top
because each time you put it back and
you do your next one that's how to think
about this
infinite set of miller planes
so you get you get this infinite set of
planes
that have i'm going to go to this
picture okay
there it is a 100 that just go on
forever
those are the miller planes and and what
they have is a spacing between them and
this
is really important so this is the next
thing i want to tell you
right so i've got so a miller plane
isn't just one it's infinite
it's an infinite number of them and
what that means is that when i give you
when i give you this
right or that or any
miller plane i know what the spacing is
between them
that is enough information because
the distance between planes
right is
actually here it's very easy to see the
distance between these planes
is a but the distance between the two oo
planes
is a over two
and in fact for a cubic cell there's a
formula that you can use for
any two planes the distance between
well let's say i'll i'll write the
notation first but the distance
and the plane there is
equal to a and the distance of a 200
plane between planes is equal to a over
2
but there's a general formula of any
h k l h k l the miller indices
those are just variables but if those
are the variables of the miller plane
then the distance between two of them is
this the length of the edge of the unit
cell a
divided by the square root of the
squares
added together h squared plus k squared
plus l squared okay h squared plus k
here so you see
okay if it's 1 0 0 that's a that works
if it's 2 0 0 a over 2 that works and
it's general
so now just by knowing but because i
figured out how to write
a plane in hkl notation i also know
the distance between these infinite
planes that becomes very very important
once we shine x-rays on crystals next
week that becomes very important
okay okay so what else can we know
from the miller planes okay
so that's the distance between them and
the other thing
that actually becomes fairly
self-evident when you play around with
this a little bit that was on the slide
before
is that the
let's see the uh or thought the plane
and the plane and the direction
with the same
miller indices
our orthogonal
orthogonal orthogonal
and you can see this from this very
simple picture there's the 001 plane
right but that's also the 001 vector
just as we defined it today so the oo1
plane
and the 001 vector are orthogonal right
so this is an example the 001 plane
is orthogonal to oh and i got to get
this right
the 001 vector oh
no commas brackets parentheses
no negatives no fractions
no infinities i followed the rules
and because of that these indices have
meaning
as i'm showing you right because of that
now you can play around with this but
this can also be fairly
straightforwardly derived things like
this
but you don't need to know that
derivation so i'm just telling it to you
okay all right so so these are the kinds
of things that you can do
with miller indices but as i said in the
beginning one of the things that you
that you would want to know what planes
you're talking about
is because you want to know what the
packing in that plane is
just like we talked about packing right
for uh well we talked about it before on
monday the atomic packing fraction
there it is the max packing fraction in
a volume
we also want to know especially if a
crystal is anisotropic
we want to know about packings in planes
right
and and so you know if you take a simple
a very simple example like a simple
cubic
there's a simple cubic lattice and now
we're all good with our notation right
there's a simple cubic crystal
okay the basis is one atom i i don't
have anything else in here those are the
atoms simple
it must be polonium right and there's
uh the 100 plane the one one o plane and
the one one one plane
one one one plane one one o plane
right one oval plane now but as you can
see
the the density of atoms in these planes
is different
the density of atoms in these planes is
different and that has a real
serious uh impact on the properties
right um so if we if we look at this
so i'll do a couple quick examples if we
look at this
example of simple cubic that's a very
easy case
right and so for simple cubic
for a simple cubic uh with uh
lattice this a is called the lattice
constant
i've mentioned it a few times lattice
constant a
then you know if we look at the 1o0
plane
then the area
is a squared the area of that plane is a
squared
oh but the question is how many atoms
are in that a squared
well you do the same thing that we did
before you but now so i'm looking at a
plane
here and i'm trying to figure out you
know how many atoms are in this up well
you know
this is being shared in this whole big
plane that goes on and on
it's being shared by four other squares
right and so there's a fourth of each
atom in there so there's one atom
effectively in that plane
again this is in one of the simplest
cases right
but the number of atoms number of atoms
is equal to one
right and so the density
of atoms per area is equal to one
over a squared now that's a pretty easy
case
right if i did the one one one one o
direction it's a little bit different
because the area is now different right
so the area
in this case is
root 2 a squared
you see that the area in in that plane
is different so the density of atoms
in the plane is different okay
so the density in the plane affects
properties and i want to give you just a
quick
uh example of that in the why this
matters because
in fact this is one of the things all
the way back to hook
and the can his cannonballs and even way
before that
people notice this stuff does it i broke
something
but it always seems to slice in a
certain way
why is that why would something always
break in the same way every time
with the same kind of you know how does
it what does whey mean here
it means like the angles that form right
so why are those angles always kind of
the same
right well it has to do with the
strength the relative strength
of the planes inside of these crystals
right
and in fact here's a beautiful uh piece
of work on stretching a wire
right so here you're taking a wire that
is crystalline
and you're pulling it and you can see
how it breaks
you can actually see how it breaks it's
breaking along the weakest plane
it's breaking along the weakest plane so
if you want to think then about well
okay how do i know how to make this
stronger
for example so it stops breaking you
know the weakest link is
is the weakest link right that was deep
and and so yeah so you but so then
that's the plane of the crystal that i
need to think about
how are atoms bonding together or
packing in in that plane
right this is real stuff this is this
comes about
in many of the properties not just the
fracture but in many of the properties
of these
of these materials the the property as i
said before
depends heavily on which plane you're in
and we'll see that more and more as one
last example
as one last example right of this you
could go a little
right so if i if i say again you go back
to your periodic table
and you take there was copper let's do
nickel
all right you take nickel
and let's see i know that the atomic
radius
of nickel is 1.52 angstroms
i've looked that up but i also know that
it's bcc and this gives it away
this gives me what i need the crystal
symmetry
the lattice gives me what i need because
once i know that it's bcc then i also
know
that the the lattice edge goes as 4r
over root 3. remember for an element
like nickel
the the packing direction is along the
body diagonal
that's what gave me this relationship
back and forth
unit cell edge radius of the atom right
what's it so that means that in in
nickel it's 3.5
angstroms and once i know what a is
well then i can know what like the the
you know in in one of the planes i say
which plane is that i don't know let's
look at the densities in the plane so
for the 100 plane
it's i'm just gonna give you the answer
point
five nine is the packing fraction
packing density right this is the
um sorry that's the fraction
all i did is i used the periodic table
to do what i just did for the simple
cubic case but now for bcc
and it's because of all the things that
we've learned in the last two days that
in those two lectures that we're able to
do this kind of calculation and i can
compare this plane
with another plane with another plane
right
and think about how the atoms are packed
differently within the anisotropy of the
crystal
okay friday bring parents
bring parents
you